rolling are we rolling hi guys my name
is amber lou and i'm here with buzzfeed
to read thirst tweets
[Music]
i'm nervous this is one of the videos
that i really wanted to do but i was
also terrified of doing let's just jump
into it
if amber lou came up to me and said hi i
would drop everything and plan on
winning right that second
what would the wedding be like please
tell and any more information amber lou
is hot
beautiful and adorable at the same time
and i don't know how that's possible
i don't know how that's possible either
amber luke can leave me on red for a
year
and then text me at 7 36 and then i
would text her back at 7
34. wait oh oh
oh that was smooth brain right there for
a second
i do leave a lot of people on red whoops
don't text me call me
this one's in cap sorry amber lou who
gave you the right to be this hot and
lethal
fire fire i don't get why people
think i'm hot or lethal like in what
ways
can someone write an explanation i
cannot answer this question
i do not understand i think if i ever
met amber lou i don't know what to do
with my hands or body
and i'd probably just end up asking her
to marry me and start a rehabilitation
farm for animals
i i'm down for this plan i'm down rescue
a lot of puppies and cats i guess meet
me first
amber oil amber luke kiss is better than
y'all cape drama opens
oh the k drama oppas well next
how much do you think it would cost to
have amber lew step on me
not for sale i will not step on what
when when did this whole
step on me thing happen i i don't want
to step on anybody can i not step on i
don't want no
no stepping on anybody maybe for charity
though i literally would give up my
entire life leave behind my friends and
family
just to live in amberleu's house as a
chair i would like
her to sit on me every day for the rest
of my life
what does this mean why not the sofa i'm
i'm on the sofa a lot more
i don't know that's creepy to me is that
creepy is it creepy like when these
thirsty tweets come at me
am i allowed to be thirsty back yo amber
lou can [ __ ] me up
anytime anywhere i'm always available
i don't want to [ __ ] anybody up movies
maybe like we can go on a walk to the
park
wholesome stuff i like wholesome stuff
guys
violence no no violence why won't amber
lou just give me a feet massage already
i don't know if it's tmi i'm not into
feet things
anyways amber lou
please eat my ass
reading that correctly next
oh great amber lou suck on my toes
please
i'm so sorry not in defeat things
yo i let amber lou choke me to death
with her legs
no no death no no choking no
no violence i um blanket snuggles
blanket snuggling is great candlelit
dinners
amber lou is so hot i want her to spit
in my mouth
because oh god are you guys okay do we
need to
have a like like a intervention or
something like i'm very concerned
uh next
amber lou please choke me and straddle
me better yet let me straddle you
okay i actually thought that i would be
taking these like pretty good i could
just be like throwing things back at you
guys but i don't know what to say
um um we can go see puppies puppies like
pet puppies you know like that that
sounds like a better plan
amber lou me choke me make me cry
make my eyes bloodshot make me hurt slap
my face kick me
guys okay guys let's let's let's
we don't we don't need that it's okay i
like hugs like simple hand-holding
you know things like that yes guys
okay if i want to read this
i'd probably come if amber lou punched
me in the face okay guys where do you
find these things
we need to talk about priorities here
healthy healthy relationships
yes we like healthy relationships
are weird that was very interesting i
understand
the intent thank you but one thing
that's for sure
i kiss better than the kdrama opus
let that be known thank you for joining
me in this buzzfeed video
reading y'all's thirst tweets um
i have a new album out called why oh it
talks about relationships maybe you guys
should listen to the album healthy
healthy
and i'll see you guys around healthy
relationship
i'm so easy just get me boba